hi can you say good morning to my
brother Hank you say good morning again
good morning
pick up inside of a trailer like that
the movie said look look it's a real
look there's like a thing there's Isaac
he's producing the movie hi sorry I'm
here on the set of The Fault in Our
Stars movie intentionally a weird angle
so that I don't giveaway locations and
Wow I've been laughing and and crying I
think they think I'm crazy because I
can't I can't keep my emotions in check
at all it's just it's just amazing so I
could catch you either said no spoilers
however I have had a great day today
like I got to hang out with Shailene and
Ansel the camera comes on you just dork
out it is on do you really paint
miniatures miniature what no I'm sorry
no I'm sorry to disappoint you though
miniature once that's right Hank Ansel
faints miniature figurines he's one of
us man I have to try some crazy angles
to keep the set out of it also I got to
hang out with Hazel's mom and dad I mean
in the movie Knotts there they're not
real if he feels real though Hank what
up we're in Pittsburgh no wait no no we
can't get Wiig location no we were in
Indiana no no we're in Alaska and also
the screenwriters are here hey wait a
second hey the Lizzie Bennet diaries one
of freakin Emmy congratulations so what
do i do on set well mostly just this I
listen to what's happening on headphones
while watching on a monitor I know this
looks very boring but it's actually
amazing to see a story that for a long
time existed only in my imagination
become visible which is why I am always
laughing and crying like from the
phalanxifor bottles to the costumes I
just keep saying oh my god what is air
and then Josh Boone the director is like
there is mostly nitrogen and oxygen at
which point I say clearly Josh you are
not spending enough time on the Internet
so Hank this is a really exciting time
but of course it's also kind of a scary
time for people who care a lot about the
book which includes me but it also and
this is important includes all of the
people who are working on this movie and
there are more than a hundred of them
Our Stars movie is happening because of
an amazing script and great producers
and a wonderful director and this
beautiful awesome cast but it is also
happening because of the many people who
have read and loved and shared the book
so generously
make no mistake Hank if people didn't
like the book there would be no movie
and we all understand that so please
know that everyone here on this set
feels a tremendous responsibility to the
story and to its readers ultimately I
think that's why it's going to be a good
movie oh my god I think that's poison
ivy Oh huge mistake so nerd fight area
thank you for making my dreams come true
Hank congratulations again on your Emmy
I will see you on Friday